europe by satellite museum le landis
college eleven months
superior
presented
president
margaritis
maria gabriel abrela
european
humanitarian
indeed good afternoon today the eu is
putting forward an initial annual
humanitarian aid budget of one and a
half billion
euro for 2022.
this comes at a moment when humanitarian
crises around the world continue to rise
nearly half a billion euro will be made
available to support those suffering
from the food and nutrition crisis as
well as conflicts in sub-saharan africa
significant funding also will be
allocated to address humanitarian needs
in the middle east and north africa
vulnerable populations and humanitarian
projects will also be supported in
southeast europe
the european neighborhoods but also in
asia and latin america now for the
specific figures i invite you to consult
our press release
thank you very much and
then let me remind you that agriculture
and fisheries ministers are meeting
today
commissioners voicovsky and kiriakides
are representing the commission at the
meeting the french presidency will
present its priorities for the next six
months and
the ministers will discuss the market
situation with regards to agricultural
products
and trade related agricultural issues
also the commission will present the
communication on carbon cycles that was
adopted by the college last month
a press conference with commissioner
wojciechowski will take place at around
18 15 this evening you can of course
follow it on europe by satellite
ensuite le vice president executive
valdis
a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
marina is your question about this your
hand is up
no you just put your hand down so it
wasn't about that
so i invite you now to raise your hand
if you have any additional questions for
nabilla on
this or other matters first i see that
odile has her hand up so
put that right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
is
moses is your question for nabila
oh thank you it could be i'm not sure
it's about western balkans
and especially about
the situation in boston has covena
can ask the question to her now
well that is not a question for nabila
it is indeed foreign affairs but i would
just want to check if there is a
question for nabila to avoid
that we go up and down from the podium
so
um i check once more if we have
questions for uh nabila yes vehua is
your question about
um uh matters which nabila carres if
that's the case go ahead
about the foreign aid the eu
i don't know how much that is going to
be for afghanistan obviously the
suffering uh worst humanitarian crisis
um secretary general guterres has called
for you know
stopping the freedom of the afghan
assets by the united states so what's
the eu's stance on that thank you
thank you very much
we
will try to answer that through nabila
first uh well i mean i'm i didn't hear
the beginning of your uh of your
question but i think it you were talking
about foreign about the aid to
afghanistan
on this i will leave my colleague maybe
anna to to give you more but as you know
the hrvp has said it several times we
are
very alarmed by the situation in
afghanistan the situation the economic
situation the humanitarian situation in
afghanistan and to give you more info on
the details of the aid
whether it is a humanitarian or
humanitarian plus
we can come either bilaterally or my
colleagues can can brief you on that
thank you very much nabila anna is ready
to to take over with additional elements
on the humanitarian uh and site
uh because there are no additional
questions for you so thank you
and anna is here
to continue on the humanitarian aspects
um hi many thanks for the question um so
i will try to cover a bit
at the ground both for humanitarian and
um
no i think ballash wants to come then
okay okay well i'll just make then a
very short introduction and i'll let my
colleague balash come to you for the
details but you will recall that uh
president on the line of course
announced
at the g20 in october a support package
of 1 billion euros to support
afghanistan and the neighbors work of
course is ongoing to operationalize the
support as part of the support we have
300 million for humanitarian purposes i
will let my colleague give you a bit
more details
on the further um on the further
part of the package
which is you know at least 250 million
of this one billion package
we are working to help sustain
livelihoods in afghanistan and also of
course make sure that people can access
can attain their basic needs in terms of
education and
health also nutrition and food safety
work is ongoing but i'll let i'll let my
colleague balash
give you more details on the
humanitarian side
thank you now barash a few more details
indeed so just to add in a few more
details on on the um on the case of
afghanistan purely in terms of
humanitarian assistance so
last year we saw the allocation of a
record high a humanitarian budget for
afghanistan multiple times we topped up
our assistance for the country over the
course of the year and in the end we
ended up with a figure of over 300
million
euro for uh humanitarian purposes now
the last piece of information i had was
that um over 220 million uh euro of this
amount was already um allocated to
different ngos operating on the ground
and international organizations with
particular emphasis on the on the united
nations of course the work continues as
to the allocation of the remaining
amount for last year now in terms of the
budget that i have announced just now
we can see that for um
broader asia and latin america
collectively we have nearly 200 million
so i would need to i would need to check
what part of this would be specifically
um for afghanistan but what i can say is
that we continue to monitor the
situation very closely on the ground we
are fully aware of the grave situation
that characterizes um
the the country at the moment and
we always stand ready of course in the
course of the year to go beyond our
initial allocations so the figures that
you find our pres in our press release
are just initial
figures which can be adjusted in the
course of the year depending on the
needs
thank you very much uh balash are there
any additional questions for balash on
this matter humanitarian aid to
afghanistan if that's the case please
keep your hand up
that is not the case in well stay hold
on are there any additional questions
for balash on other matches that he
follows budgetary measures or
others
i believe that oliver has a question for
you go ahead oliva
hi hello um
i have a question on um this
matter of degener and the appointment of
the uh
new director general that's been going
on for several weeks now here in
brussels and politico now made a very
good expose of the issue at hand
which is that
the current permanent representative of
poland is apparently very interested in
the job and has a very influential
support of this
but i would be interested in
your view at the outlook that the two
most important posts in europe's
enlargement policy might
be occupied by very close associates of
the two governments that are on the
article 7
procedures poland and hungary what kind
of message this sends to these countries
in the western balkans thank you thank
you very much for your question um
oliver so obviously balaji can run you
through the the process that we have for
appointing um senior officials and the
history regarding the recruitment for
this specific post but obviously we have
absolutely no comment to make about any
possible outcome of a recruitment
process which is ongoing so um
no um speculation or discussion about
any possible results but just strictly
on the process which was followed yes so
so um i think we are talking about a
vacancy at uh degenerate specifically
that of the director general which is an
ongoing uh process there is a vacancy
here which has been published
internally institutionally and also
externally um the procedure involves
five major um stages um it is ongoing um
and strictly speaking of course we
cannot speculate on on the outcome of
this procedure the final decision is to
be taken by the college and as usual if
such a decision is taken will be
communicating on the day
thank you very much oliver you have a
follow-up question please go ahead
thank you um
more generally i've had a look at the
organizational chart of of dg near uh
recently and it struck me that several
important benjamin posts are vacant for
quite a while already
including this one this is very
extraordinary because if you look at
other such important dgs uh these these
top posts are filled because they're
politically important they are important
to
promote the political aims uh of the
objectives of the front of the line
commission how do you explain that so
many managerial posts indigenous
are vacant are people not interested in
taking these posts are they maybe not
confident in incorporating with
commissioner vargas
on these matters what's your take on
this thank you
thank you very much oliver there are two
balash will of course not be able to
speculate um in any way
about any possible reasons that you
think may motivate
colleagues to work in one dg
as opposed to another i don't know if
there are any specific uh
additional elements to add regarding the
vacancy
rate uh in
in there and in other dgs but sometimes
appointments at senior management level
can take can take some time because a
complex set of skill is necessary skills
are necessary
in order to fulfill
vacancies at that level anything else to
add yes i mean i do have statistics not
right now at my disposal but after the
midday i can share with you the
significant number of uh senior
appointments which have been made since
the moment this commission uh took
office and um in those statistics you
can we can see that indeed a significant
amount of progress has been made in
filling senior management positions and
the work will continue
on the days of college meetings so you
might expect further announcements from
our site
all right thank you very much balash are
there any additional questions for
balash on this specific subject
degener or senior management
appointments in general
i see that moses has his hand up do you
also have a question about this mosey
hello
yes i think it's my question is
indirectly at least linked
with this question we were raised by
olivier but
it's connected with djinni of course and
with its let's say commissioner mr
fahili i think we discussed that last
week
about the situation in bosnia scotland
and so
i suppose if this new has
staffing or manning problems i suppose
that's quite serious in view of the
situation not only in boston but
generally in western balkans
i'm thinking about last week's audit
report by ekka on the problems in
promoting the rule of law in the west
african countries
but let me go back to my specific
question
which is about that leaked document or
let's say mission report from the
delegation in boston
to brussels
about the situation in the country
i understand that as you said last week
you don't comment on leaked documents so
i would like to ask if you could confirm
or clarify two issues which have been
reported in media
one is the question if there is a kind
of moratorium when it comes to
the public steps has say
plans to withdraw unilaterally from the
state institutions in boston's governor
if let's say the commissioner managed to
reach such an agreement with them
for half a year
and secondly
if in the meantime something has started
in the process to try to solve the
constitutional problems which were
mentioned i think
in that league document i'm thinking
about the question about state property
in the country
and how that should be allocated
and what should let's say the office of
the high representative have
in that process in solving that issue
has any have any discussions started to
solve the issue since the commissioner
visited the boston cabinet in november
last year
thank you thank you very much for your
questions
moses it's a it's a varied set of
questions pertaining geographically to
the same region
as covered by degener but otherwise
balash will be free to
uh to leave the stage because the answer
uh now refers more to
the follow-up and evolutions in the
region at political level so in relation
to the first part of your question which
made a link between uh the uh situation
of a vacancy at the junior and our um um
policy or let's say
work towards the western balkans balkans
allow me to say that the commission is
fully operational uh focused uh and
active in relation to
um our partners
in the western balkans so no link is to
be made
between an administrative vacancy and
our very active
work
in partnership with
western balkan countries then in
relation to the second part of your
question uh i i basically
uh boil it down to whether has there
been any progress made since that visit
um of the commissioner i'll give the
floor to um to anna to provide an answer
hi many thanks to the question uh mostly
i think that um you know from our
perspective here uh we want to once
again reiterate um that the eu is fully
committed to territorial integrity and
sovereignty of bosnia-herzegovina and
we've rejected any proposal that would
undermine the constitutional framework
of bosnia natina now this is a very
clear position of the european union of
the commission which by the way
commissioner rahay
very clearly conveyed also when he was
when he was during his mission in
sarajevo
at the end of last year
and again as you very well said indeed
we do not comment on leaked documents
but our position is extremely extremely
extremely clear on this issue um and of
course you know we continue to expect
that uh you know all eu all all leaders
in bosnia-herzegovina return to dialogue
allow for the fully functioning of the
state institutions in bosnia and again
avoid any unilateral steps that risk
you know
[Music]
further
further
taking away
bosnia from its eu path
so this is a very very clear uh call
that we continue to make
um
you've made
a last reference point maybe to the to
the um to the property um i think that
you very well know that the rule of law
is a cornerstone of the accession
process and of course must be upheld
and this also of course includes
respecting um
constitutional courts rulings
and of course issues related to um to uh
state property should be regulated by
a state-level law
discussed and agreed among all parties
in uh the bosnia and turkovin parliament
thank you very much anna
are there any additional questions on
this matter
if so please just raise your hand
not the case are there any additional
questions for anna on the panoply of
matches that she covers
yes i believe that marina has a question
for you so go ahead marina
i have a question regarding the
referendum in serbia but also on the
dialogue between belgrade and pristina
so i i don't know if it's anna or peter
who can who can answer on this
so uh
yes on the first one yes on the first
one
anna and on the second part of the
question it will be peter
this will be pizza okay thank you uh
anna uh
well uh yesterday we had the
uh referendum in in serbia regarding the
constitutional changes and one of the
motives for this referendum was also the
invitation from the eu
regarding the reform of the rule of law
can you explain to the citizens of
serbia
from the eu side why this
referendum was important and one why
these changes are important for for
serbia eu path
marina for the question i'm sure that
you've seen commissioner vaihay's tweet
following the referendum where of course
voters supported the change of the
of the constitution to with a view to
reinforce the judicial independence um
of course we welcome this important step
and commitment uh to the eu path um
uh the eu welcomes the completion of
this important step uh in the question
institutional reform process as i said
with the view to uh enhancing and
strengthening the dependence of the
judiciary in line with serbia's
strategic choice to exceed uh to the
european union
um of course we all know that of course
the reform process to strengthen the
independent of the judiciary which is
absolutely uh key and fundamental to the
accession process um does not end here
and of course
will need to uh continue and uh you know
that the number of laws will of course
need to be amended uh to effectively
implement now the uh the constitutional
amendments and from our side very
clearly we will continue to work um very
closely with the serbian authorities on
this ambitious
reform agenda to advance of course the
integration so yes this is a very
important step of course more work needs
to be done but it's a very important
step uh showing as well commitment of
course to the eu reform
process thank you very much anna before
going to the second part of the question
i'm checking once more if there are
other questions for anna today
no that's
all for you today thank you very much
anna and i will invite peter to join us
for
the
political
dialogue
but the question was not asked yet no
we just know briefly the topic but the
question was not asked yet so i'll
invite marina to ask it
to ask it thank you so so peter the the
question is that um uh pristina once
more disregarded the calls from eu to
allow this referendum yesterday to be
held in in in territory of kosovo
so uh my question is actually
does eu and united states also as a
partner of eu has any kind of influence
any kind of instrument to to to make any
uh pressure or move in pristina to
respect the values and the standards of
eu and also uh we see the the same thing
happening in the dialogue between
belgrade and pristina which is postponed
and blocked ex
again because of the priesthood so do we
have any new steps regarding the
continuation of the dialogue between
belgium and christina thank you
thank you marina you touched upon
several aspects so i will try to go
one by one on them first of all on the
lack of possibility for serbs in kosovo
to participate in this referendum the
position of the european union was very
clear already before that all eligible
serps in kosovo should have had the
possibility to cast their votes through
the collection of ballots operation
facilitated by the oec we regret that it
was not possible to conduct such an
operation collection of ballots this is
something that has been done in the past
facilitated by the eu by the oec this is
long-standing established practice such
operations have taken place in the past
in 2012 2014 2016 17 and 2020 so this is
really regrettable now the consent of
both sides would have been necessary in
order to make such operations possible
and feasible and while we as the
european union have always supported uh
the negotiations between both parties
through the oac in the end it's on the
parties and themselves to negotiate and
find an agreement on these and although
there is no agreement within the eu
facilitated dialogue between uh pristine
and belgrade on organizing serbian
elections in kosovo
we would now expect the parties to start
negotiating uh the mutually agreeable
modalities which would allow serps in
kosovo to vote in future serbian
elections and we are ready to facilitate
this
this is one of the instruments you've
been asking about so what is our tool to
to achieve this well our engagement with
the partners both with serbia and kosovo
but also with the united states and
other partners uh using our influence
in the negotiations and in interactions
with them
when it comes to dialogue as such it's
not true that dialogue is postponed the
work on the dialogue continues with
everyday work and engagement by all
those who are involved in it at least on
the eu side that means high
representative burrell
i can only recall his interactions with
prime minister kurti and president butch
last week the actions um meetings
interactions and activities by eu
special representative for the dialogue
so he continues his everyday work and
outreach the fact that there is not um
high level dialogue high level meeting
in the dialogue is is not proof that the
dialogue is postponed so the work
continues and once the conditions will
be right then there will be another
meeting either the level of cheap
negative negotiators or um at the level
of prime minister and president so we
work together with the eu partners with
other partners such as united states
very closely in order to
bring this message home to both parties
that the progress in the eu facilitated
dialogue is necessary as soon as
possible and not for us
but for the benefit of the people both
in kosovo and serbia
thank you very much peter are there any
additional questions for peter on the
subject marina i believe you have a
follow-up question go ahead
just a short follow-up thank you uh but
peter uh the clear uh the clear sign
that
there was no referendum held in in in
kosovo uh regarding the serbian
constitutional changes is the signal
that the eu doesn't have any kind of
influence on priesthood at this point do
can you agree with this and is there
anything else that
you can do
except just give a call for pristina to
to cooperate
of course i don't agree with this i mean
the eu has leveraged the eu has
influence because in the end kosovo
wants to enter the european union there
are clear criteria based on which such a
process is being conducted and if
someone is not respecting the pattern
not sticking to the principles and
criteria and conditions then of course
you cannot expect to proceed on that
path but again the
it is very regrettable that the serbs in
kosovo did not have the chance to
cast their votes through this collection
of ballots operation and that's why we
expect both parties and we are using all
our instruments we have and all our
engagement with both serbia and kosovo
to make sure that they start to
negotiate mutually acceptable modalities
which will allow serbs in kosovo to
participate and vote in future serbian
elections this is very important and for
this we are focusing now our engagement
with the partners
thank you very much peter are there any
additional questions for peter on this
subject
yes go ahead
yes peter is a follow-up on your final
answer would we expect that you would
invite parties to discuss and find the
common solution
before serbian elections meaning before
april the 3rd
in order to avoid another
identical scenario
as i mentioned we are in a constant
engagement with the parties we are
raising issues which are important we do
not prefer to use media messaging so of
course when we have
elections uh coming up in april we want
to find solutions before the elections
but on the modalities and the exact
steps and timelines and processes
we prefer to to keep it for the
communication for our normal discrete
communication with the partners
thank you
any additional questions for peter
that is not the case either thank you
very much peter
so do you have any other additional
questions for us today on any other
method
that is not the case so thank you very
much to everybody do not forget that we
have several press conferences
uh today in relation to
the council meetings that i referred to
and
also tune in for the college readout
which will take place tomorrow in the
afternoon following the meeting
of the college and yes until they stay
until then stay well bye-bye
you